brice c'est ton meilleur ami
ces cours rejoint mois au plus vite
quand le premier avion le premier avion
s'il te plaît oui premier avion pour
vous ah ben je sais pas moi [ __ ] mais
toi ça sent bon vent à la terre polluée
on coupe presse qui poussent mais en
fait ce n'est pas en danger
ah non c'est pas moi qui suivront tanger
tétouan qu en danger
j'ai cru que j'allais voir tout le film
brice 3 à bac 4 6 1
salut les bitches saffar c'est pas dit
si toi mais moi je viens de nice écoute
moi bien le pom boys ici c'est pas ton
pote c'est sneijder 2 go alors va jouer
dans le sable avec ton souhaita
quéquette avant que je t'écris parce que
c'est encore lui que méchant
par exemple jamais faire tu m'as bien
regardez d'ailleurs j'aimerais bien voir
ta gueule mais juste un sourire pour
halloween
mais c'est quoi
petite tache l'un le trou serment en fin
à la partie active qui représentent
environ 7% fréquents pour donner un
ordre d'idée une huître c8 rire à neuf
ces neuf il ya quelqu'un qui vont
chercher la souplesse
bonjour jours j'avais ou à hossegor ah
ben moi aussi est monté non mais je vais
trouver mieux
de l'autre côté de la route tu trouveras
la plage de faire peur à rester gentil
merci de toute ma gueule non juste de ta
voix